[Müzik]
Şu arkadaki iki fotoğrafı Türkiye nerede
çektiğimi tahmin etmenizi istesem tahmin
edenler çıkacak mı acaba
ben Doğa fotoğrafçısıyım yaklaşık 10
yıldır seyahat ediyorum ve böyle doğa
fotoğrafları çekiyorum Türkiye'nin
birçok bölgesinde bu tarz bilinmeyen
yerleri fotoğraflamaya çalışıyorum Ben
yıllardır doğada ne görsem hep bir
şekilde Mesela örnek veriyorum Bir Gün
batımını görüp etkilendiğimde onu
sözlerinle anlatmaya çalıştım
arkadaşlarıma bundan bahsettiğim de
herhangi bir örnek veriyorum bir kar
yağışını Bir Gün batımını anlatmaya
çalıştığımda o karşıda hiçbir zaman o
istediğim tepki alamadım Belki bunu
sizde yaşıyorsunuzdur hayatınızda sonra
bunları Fotoğrafla anlatmaya çalıştım ve
kendimi bir görsel Öykü anlayışsız
olarak tanımlıyorum
Tabii bu fotoğraf süreci Doğa
fotoğrafçılığının Hem iyi yönleri Hem
kötü yönleri var Bugün size biraz
bunlardan bahsedeceğim önce buna nasıl
başladığımdan bahsedeyim ben tabii
fotoğraf çekmek istiyordum ama bir
Fotoğraf makinem bile yoktu arkadaşımdan
ödünç aldığım makineyle her gün çıkıp
fotoğraf çekerdim Okuduğum üniversitede
kütüphanedeki bütün fotoğraf kitaplarını
okumuştum ama tabii bir Fotoğraf makinem
olmadığı için hiçbir zaman istediğim
kadar çekim yapamıyordum ilk kez Annem
kredi çekerek bana bir fotoğraf makinesi
aldı
tam dedim Okey işte ilk kez Fotoğraf
makinem oluyor her şey yoluna giriyor
derken o zamanlar bir öğrenci evimiz
vardı bu adamın katında yaşıyorduk oraya
hırsız girdi o fotoğraf makinemi çaldı
Tabii sonra yine dünya başıma yıkılmıştı
Ama tabi her şey bitti derken sonra bu
öyle bir şeye sebep oldu ki bu bir
şekilde bana Sponsor olacak bir firmanın
kulağına gitmiş bu dünyanın en büyük
fotoğraf üretilenlerden bir tanesi o
zamanlar böyle yani kendi imkanımla
sahip olamayacağım bir makine verdi ve o
sponsorluk o makineyle izlanda'ya
yolculuk yaptın bu İzlanda yolculuğu
benim hayatımın en iyi yolculuklarından
bir tanesiydi çünkü daha önce
yaşamadığım birçok şeyi orada yaşadım
mesela kuzey ışıkları kuzey ışıklarını
ilk kez orada gördüm ve altında kamp
yaptım Tam istediğim tarzda fotoğrafları
çekebileceğim imkanlar yani Mesela
buzulları açıldım buzulların
içerisindeki bir gökkuşağını çektim bu
tam benim çekmek istediğim şey doğada
Nadir olan şeyleri en şey haliyle
insanlara Ya ben bunu anlatsam bir
şekilde kafasında canlandıramıyor
insanlar ama bu şekilde canlandıracak
imkanları buldum bu benim hayatımda
birçok şey değiştirilir çünkü hayatım
tamamen hani böyle her şey bitti derken
Böyle bir şeye sebep olması bunun beni
inanılmaz motive etti ve bundan sonra ne
yaşasam bu aklıma geldi
ilk fotoğrafta gösterdiğim yerde Aslında
Mesela benim arkadaşlarıma yine
anlattığım defalarca hayatımda gittiğim
en iyi yer dediğim yerdi ve orası
Hakkari Ama hiçbir şekilde arkadaşlarım
bana diyordu ya hani Hakkari Ne alaka
falan diyordu Hatta birlikte gidelim
dediklerinde bile hani bir soru işareti
oluşuyordu kafalarında tabii şimdi bu
fotoğrafı gösterdiğimde hakarete çektim
fotoğrafları tam olarak ne demek
istediğimi anladılar ve hayatım boyunca
hep Ben bu fotoğrafların peşinden gittim
sonra şimdi burada bir Hani bir başarı
hikayesi anlatmak istersem hayatımdaki
Hani başarı başardım diyebileceğim şey
küçüklükte hayalini kurduğum şeyi şu an
gerçeğim haline getirmek ben hani
küçükken belgesel çekmekle fotoğraf
çekmek istiyordum ve şu an onu yaşıyorum
ama tabii ki ben de bu esnada birçok
şekilde kayboldum yani ne yapacağımı
bilemedim mesela gidip Ben üniversiteden
İnşaat Mühendisliği okudum ama tabii ki
inşaat mühendisi benim hayalim değildi
bir şekilde ailemin ya da Çevremdeki
insanların hayaliydi ve onu ben kendi
başlarım olarak görüyordum Ama o benim
başlarım değildi ve Hani içimdeki o
fotoğraf şeyini kaybetmedim ve bu
şekilde hani ne kadar kaybolsam da aynı
şekilde yoluma devam ettim
burada size söyleyebileceğim şey Yani
bazen yaşadığım Yani kendi hayalimiz
olduğunu düşündüğümüz şeyler
başkalarının hayalleri olabiliyor ve biz
onun farkında olamıyoruz O yüzden ben
hani her zaman şeyi örnek aldım küçükken
ben ne istiyordum Hani gerçek hayalim o
saf duygulardaki hayalim neydi Şu an
onun peşinden gitmeye çalışıyorum ben
normalde 18 yaşa kadar Malatya'da
büyüdüm hiç seyahat eden birisi bile
değildim belki sadece bir gezi ile
İstanbul'a gitmiştik o da lise geziydi
Onun dışında seyahat etmiyordum Ama şunu
yapmayı biliyordum korkularımın üzerine
gitmeyi çok iyi biliyordum ve bugün
alaskadan Kuzey kutbuna havai'ye birçok
yere seyahat ediyorum
Tabii bunları sosyal medyada
paylaşıyorum ve birçok insan böyle her
şeyin sorunsuz ilerlediğini görüyor Ve
hep o fotoğrafları o doğal
fotoğraflarını görünce her şeyin ne
kadar estetik ve ne kadar güzel benim
hayatımda hiçbir sorun olmadığını
düşünebiliyor ama o fotoğrafları
çekerken yaşadığım birkaç andan
bahsetmek istiyorum yani hatta böyle
şöyle söyleyeyim ölümle burun buruna
geldim Hatta kesin artık burada öldüm
dediğim anlar yaşadım bunlardan bir
tanesi Bu gördüğünüz fotoğraf benim
Giresun'da gittiğim bir buzul Gölü oraya
gittiğimde o kadar iyi hissediyordum ki
inanılmaz mutluyduk Biraz geç kaldık
akşam dönüşte geçtik dönerken inanılmaz
yağmur yağıyordu biz de bir köy
yolundayız yani hayat belki Hani
milyonda bir denk gelecek bir şey oldu
bir heyelan yaşandı ve Kayalar gözümün
önünde direkt bizim Aracımızın üzerine
düştü Hatta şöyle göstereyim Bir tanesi
arka camdan içeri girdi aracın üstüne
ezildi işte kaportası delindi falan
lastiklerimizin hepsi patladı
Hatta ön camına denk gelseydi Belki şu
an burada bir konuşmayı yapamıyor
olacaktım Tabii Hani bu Normalde bir
insanında travmaya atacağını
düşünürsünüz Ben de öyle kendi öyle
olacak diye düşünüyordum ama hala yola
devam ettim sonra bir başka Hikayem Var
bir başka hikayemde var ve o artık her
şey bitti dediğim yer ve Aslında
fotoğrafın bana ne ifade ettiğini Hani
fotoğrafı ne kadar değer verdiğimi
anlatan bir hikaye
Türkiye'deki bir şehre Bir yaban
hayvanının fotoğraflamaya gittik oraya
bana hayvanı şu an İsim vermiyor
vermeyeceğim ama böyle Türkiye'de 50 60
tane kalmış son hani son 50-60 tane
kalmış bir tür diyebilirim onun
fotoğraflamaya gittiğimiz yerde yine O
gölde olduğu gibi o kadar mutlu
hissediyoruz ki ya buraya kimse girmemiş
Her şey ne kadar güzel kelebekler
uçuşuyor kimlere bile kimse basmamış
Tabii Tamam bunu düşünürken yukarıdan
bir silah sesi geldi Biz de o kanyonun
en dibindeyiz Tabii bir şekilde hani bu
olayı çözmeye çalıştık ve kendimi bir
anda o silahın karşısında buldum
böyle ellerim havada Beklerken şey bizi
öldüreceğini söyleyen adam şey yaptı
telefonunu bir arkadaşın aradı ve şunu
söyledi Ben bunları öldürüyorum Sen de
araçlarını yak sonra gel dedi Ben dedim
tamam herhalde öldüm orada adama bir
cümle kurdum o yani hiç unutmam dedim
Tamam abi Tamam biz öldüreceksin bizi
ama aracı yakmaya dedim araçta da o
zaman benim hard disklerim var hiç yedek
almadım o güne kadar 3 tane hard diskim
dedim Lütfen abi aracı yapma
fotoğraflarım var tam bizi öldür dedim
Bunu niye anlatıyorum Bu da hani benim
kendime Hani fotoğrafa ne kadar değer
verdiğimi anlattığım hikayelerden bir
tanesidir Ben sosyal medyada
paylaşıyorum bu fotoğrafları
Instagram'da 700.000'e yakın takipçim
var Her şey bir şekilde orada pozitif
görülüyor sorunsuz görünüyor ama
Madalyonun Bir de ee diğer bir yüzü var
bizim doğaya verdiğimiz zararlar Ben
Türkiye'de çok fazla seyahat ettiğim
için artık Türkiye'deki değişimi çok net
görebiliyorum aynı yerlere mesela
Karadeniz'e 10 senedir defalarca gittim
Tabii artık seyahat ederken eskiden ne
kadar pozitif duyguların varsa şimdi
yerini negatif duygulara bıraktığı anlar
oluyor Oradaki değişimi görmek o doğaya
giderken doğaya verdiğimiz zararı görmek
Hani oraya bir şey için gidiyoruz mesela
Karadeniz'de geçen bir Göle gittim daha
önceden de gitmiştim oraya ve bir sene
arayla oraya bir otel yapmışlar ve Oteli
yapan kişi bütün gölün çevresindeki
sarılıkları yok etmiş Hani oraya doğal
bir otel yapmaya çalışıyor ve insanların
doğaya gelmesini bekliyor ama o
sazlıktaki yaşayan kuşu ya mesela oraya
gittiğimizde bize neyi hissettirecek o
kuşun sesi o kurbağanın sesi ya da diğer
canlılar bunları yok ediyoruz ve
gittiğimiz yeri doğaya kaçalım derken
şehirleşiyoruz Hatta ben bir daha
fotoğrafçısı olarak
bir yandan yaban hayvanlarını da
çekiyorum ilk kez boz ayı çekmek için
yola çıktım
ormanda boza yeri akşama kadar aradık
ama bulamadık ve akşamında dönerken
şehir çöpüne uğradık seyir çöplüğünde şu
Fotoğrafı çektim bir ayıyı bir daha
fotoğrafçısı Türkiye'de Bir çöplükte
çekebiliyor onların oradaki ormandaki
alanını o kadar daraltmışız ki ayıların
gidebilecek hiçbir yeri yok
beslenebilecekleri meyve ağaçları yok
hiçbir şey yok Normalde Bunlar göç eden
Ormanların Arasından seyahat göç eden
türler ve hepsi mecburen çöpten
besleniyor ve ben de ilk ayı fotoğrafımı
Bir çöplükte çektim Hatta ayıyla ilk
karşılaşmamıdır
Hatta geçen de defalarca kurutulmaya
çalışılmış bir yere gittim Burası
Kayseri'de sultan sazlığı orada şey
yaptım liseli liseli bir grup gelmişti
oraya bir Doğa gezintisi yapmışlar biraz
kulak misafiri oldum hani orada doğaya
zarar vermeyen bir ahşap köprü yapılmış
çocuk şöyle bir şey söyledi ya keşke
dedi şöyle geniş bir yol yapsana da biz
rahat rahat yürüsek böyle kalabalık bir
gruptu Tabii burada Onu suçlamıyorum Ama
şunu çok fazla düşünüyorum Biz yıllardır
Ben 28 yaşındayım yıllarca birçok eğitim
aldım liseye gittim üniversiteye gittim
ortaokula gittim ama hiçbir yerde bana
doğaya dair bir şey öğretilmedi ben de
bilmiyorum ve şu an öğrenmeye
çalışıyorum O örnek benim için çok iyi
oldu Ben hatta onu Instagram'da
paylaştım O Sazlığı ya dedim ne kadar
muhteşem bir yer Çünkü o 300 tane kuşa
ev sahipliği yapan bir yer ya Birisi
bana mesaj attı dedi ki ya buranın hani
neyi muhteşem ya hani Burası bataklık
dedi hani biz doğadaki Hani sevdiğimiz
şeyleri bile şey yapıyoruz Hani bir
şekilde kendi estetik kay kanalımıza
göre şekillendirilmişiz mesela her şey
Doğa denize aklınıza orman geliyor ama o
sazlıkta yaşayan birçok hayvanı birçok
canlıyı düşünemiyoruz Orada mesela
300'den fazla kuş türü orada dinleniyor
ve defalarca kurtulmaya çalışılmış bir
yer
Bu da bu fotoğrafta Ayrı bir olay burası
yine Hakkari ben buraya 5 saat yürüyerek
ulaştım Türkiye'nin en büyük buzulu
Burası Cilo dağları oraya kadar yürüyüş
yaptım ve oraya giden insanın Hani orayı
sevebileceğini düşünüyordum yani oraya
zarar verilecek bir eylemde bulunmasını
bekliyor böyle paradokski oraya kadar
yürüyorsan o kadar bu şeyi alıyorsan
göze bir şekilde orayı seviyorsundur ve
sevdiğin şeyi zarar vermezsin değil mi
burada bu çöple karşılaştım Bunun
dışında orada Ateş yakıp piknik yapan
insanlar vardı o kadar şaşırıyorum ve o
kadar şey geliyor ki bana yani kafamda
çözemiyorum Hani bunu doğru örneği nedir
diye düşünürken daha önce o İzlanda
gezisinde Yaşadığım bir olay aklıma
geldi Size ondan da bahsetmek istiyorum
bu mesela ben izlanda'da ilk kez
buzullara gittim Orada da bir gelin
vardı ve dün fotoğrafı çekiliyorlardı
kızın elinden uçan balonlar bir şekilde
uçtu buzun ortasına gitti orada hemen
herkes oraya tıraşlandık ya Sadece bir
balon için plastik balon buzulları
açılıyor hemen sol ayakları atladılar ve
o balonu geri getirdiler Yani insanlar
ben şimdi burada bir şeyleri anlatırken
kötü örneklere Hani bu iyi örneği
vermenin sorumluluğunu hissediyorum Hani
onların duaya bakış açısı ve Hani koruma
şeyi ve Bizimki bilmiyorum yani bunu
hala çözemiyorum Bu iyi bir örnek olsun
diye burada Bırakmak istedim
şöyle Doğa eğitimi derken gerçekten hani
biz Doğaya Karşı doğayı tanımıyoruz
bugün Sokağa çıktığımızda 5 tane kuş
türünü bilmiyoruz 5 tane kuş türünün
ismini bile sayamıyoruz Normalde doğada
öyle bir eğlence var ki yani buna
birazcık odaklanmaya başladığımızda
şeyden mesela Afrika'dan göç eden bir
kuş Geliyor İstanbul'daki bahçemize ve
bahçemizde mola veriyor bizim ona orada
görme şansımız var ve biz bu hani bunun
hiç farkında olmadığımız için ya da
baksak da görmediğimiz için belki onu
bir serçe sandığımız için hiç farkında
değiliz ama orada öyle bir olay var ki o
kadar heyecanlandırıcı bir şey ki
Aslında bu aslında bizim bu eğitim
hayatımızda mutlaka bu dua eğitiminin bu
hayvanlara canlara karşı yaklaşımımızın
mutlaka olması gerektiğini düşünüyorum
ve ben de kendimi burada aynı sınıfa
sokarak Ben de yeni yeni öğrenen birisi
olarak yani Ben doğayı her zaman kendi
kılavuzum olarak görüyorum bana
öğretilen her şeyi doğaya bakarak
sorguluyorum birçok şey öğretildi 28
yaşındayım bunların neyin o o doğru olup
olmadığını nereden anlayabilirim Ben
bunu bunun için doğaya dönüyorum ve
doğadaki yaş sayısı canlıların kendi
arasındaki ilişkiyi gözlemliyorum mesela
arkadaşlarımı alıyorum bir seyahate
çıkıyoruz Karanlık Bir yerdeyiz
Samanyolu'na bakıyoruz arkadaşım diyor
ki ben Samanyolu İlk kez gördüm
Samanyolu her gün tepemizde Samanyolu
galaksisi Yıldızlar her zaman tepemizde
ama biz bunu göremiyoruz Ben mesela
Hatta Geçen yine böyle bir şey yaşadım
ilk kez Yıldız Kayıştan tanıklık etmiş
mesela arkadaşım ben bunları ben bunları
yaşadım diye anlatmak istemiyorum Ben de
bunlara dikkat etmiyordum sadece insan
dikkat etmeye başladıkça tanıdıkça
bunları daha fazla görebiliyor ve görüp
bildiğin şeyi daha fazla
koruyabiliyorsun çünkü yoksa tanımadığım
bir şeyden her zaman korkarsın ve
korktuğum şey zaten koruyamazsın Hatta
arada bir mesafe koyarsın Ben bugün
mesela ayıyı çektiğimi söylediğimde Ben
Başak tilki kurt birçok hayvanı çektim
Türkiye'de bana hiçbirisi bir saldırma
hamlesinde ya da herhangi bir şey de
bulunmadı ama bunu nerede anlatsam hani
ya ayı şöyle yavrusu varken saldırır
şöyle saldırır böyle saldırır Aslında
öyle bir şey yok ve biz tanım
izlediğiniz için korktuğumuz için
onların değerini de bilmiyoruz bugün
işte ayılarımız çöplükten besleniyor ya
da gittiğimiz yerlerde kuşların
yuvalarını ormanları bir şekilde yok
etmeye çalışıyoruz Umarım doğayla
bağımızda hiçbir zaman kaybetmeyiz ve
baktığımız şeyleri görmeyi daha iyi fark
edebiliriz herkese teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]